volkswagen has added an all track
version to its current Passat range
permanent all-wheel drive a modified
chassis and under bodyguards all come as
standard with the new model buyers can
choose from one of four turbocharged
engines three diesels and one gasoline
unit the base model of the Passat
Alltrack with a 115 kilowatt diesel
engine sells for upwards of thirty eight
thousand five hundred fifty euros in
Germany British luxury carmaker Bentley
is introducing its first SUV the been
Tiger weighing in at two thousand four
hundred kilograms this tank of a vehicle
is equipped with a 12-cylinder engine
eking 447 kilowatts of power out of six
litres of cubic capacity the been taken
can make the sprint from 0 to 100
kilometres an hour and just 4.1 seconds
the SUV will have its world premiere at
the frankfurt motor show later this
month
the pure and crafted festival in Berlin
isn't just about motorcycles it's also
about handmade design and retro
lifestyle products
the cool of two-wheelers are what people
are here for but some fans are also
looking for musical inspiration
I'm looking for some IDs Tengu music
yeah BMW motorrad is co-sponsoring the
event so on the festival grounds you'll
find plenty of beamers each one of them
customized a legendary boxer engine
beamers are now cult objects as our
harley-davidson choppers bike meets tend
to attract an older clientele but not
this one
isn't it nah [ __ ] [ __ ] that's this new
generation as our BMW executive calls
them are really into customizing again
and he's really glad that they found
them that there are young people for
whom riding motorcycles is cool again
that wasn't the case for a long time and
looking around here you can see how
young and varied the crowd are they like
this lifestyle that includes a yearning
for handmade things handmade music and
made jeans and made belts and customized
bikes some are amazingly creative
creative of hot so I get some tire
fantastisch a customized bikes here the
festival even attracted Japanese bike
fans their projects are based on the BMW
are 90 model this motorcycle is fairly
minimalistic that makes it individually
adaptable so the possibilities for
customization are nearly endless each
bike is completely unique
handmade is the trend at the pure and
crafted festival as this craftsman
confirms
they can people can see cool bikes and
meet cool folks who make cool things you
know handmade stuff truly well-made like
the leather maker who makes great
leather products a guy does silkscreen
t-shirts and I do custom paint jobs for
helmets and motorcycles these are people
who practice their trade sell their
stuff and who really believe in their
product their heart is in it relics from
the past are also worshiped here the
legendary Motordrome has been around
since 1928 it's the world's oldest wall
of death still traveling kadavo we want
to show people how wonderful life is and
it gets even better when you write a
motorcycle the next generation of bike
fans is waiting in the wings but for now
they'll stick to the virtual Highway
Oh